what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell that we
are going to be notified of my daily
videos guys it's episode 101 out of
Miami one more time let's clap
today I have a lovely guest host
it's hard
tell the people who you are I am the
lead attorney here on YouTube I have a
channel it's kind of Min Centric letting
men know about uh divorce law child
custody child support alimony property
division all of that good stuff so if
you are in a relationship with a woman
and it's going pretty far you might want
some information so you can check me out
if you're thinking about getting married
and today we have a lovely panel um why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact about yourself
starting with a special guest Anton
Daniel
Anton from antondaniels.com
um multiple different channels including
the lapif network uh the millionaire
Morning Show and then Anton Daniels uh I
am 40. I am married been married for 18
years since I was 22 years old and I
live my life like an open book
some mood
you want to go no you go okay uh my name
is Jamie Lee Simmons I'm a stand-up
comedian and I am the co-host of the two
girls one blunt podcast
uh I'm 28. I am single and a fun fact
hmm
I wasn't prepared for that oh I'm gonna
make this easy for you guys to [ __ ] on
me later I have three cats
I'm the cats it's a cat I got a dog
uh hi my name is Emily Wade I'm one of
the other co-hosts of the two girls one
blunt podcast I am 24 and yeah I almost
said 22 I'm like 19 in my head
um but I am single and a fun fact about
me
um I'm a second degree black belt oh
that's cool
uh in Cambo in combo amazing
so today
I have a question
all right let's start so what do you
guys feel like women don't understand
about men and what don't men understand
about women are you asking us
yeah I'm Gonna Let You Go guys go first
oh that's so kind of you to let me go
first I'm a gentleman
okay what do women not understand about
men and what do men not understand about
women oh you put me on the spot Anton
um
yeah you could start with you could
start with um
what men don't understand about women
because you know okay what men don't
understand about women
don't want to go first yeah okay
I think women don't understand about
women is and a lot of the conversations
are about like security and being a
provider and I think a lot of men don't
realize how important emotional like
security and safety is
um I think they think about it as like
I'm protecting you like physically or
I'm gonna take care of you with income
but I think taking care of somebody's
mind and soul is just important I think
a lot of women value that
um what women don't understand about men
I think women read into what men say and
do too much instead of just taking it
it's like for what it is like straight
value men are pretty straightforward
they tell you who they are they show you
with their actions and a lot of women
will read into that like it's something
else or try to prove like oh I can get
them to change you know
but do you think that men care about
what women think or what it is that they
care about because we slot women right
like we slot women based off of what we
need them for versus what women think
that we need them for right so we slot
women for example it's the ones that
we'll have sex with or we'll bust down
and then it's the ones that we'll take
seriously and will marry though right so
are all women the same as far as that
emotional connection that they feel like
that they need with a man in order for
them to really really feel like they're
connected
I think that there's a huge disconnect
with everyone emotionally so I think
that with a lot of women
have that expectation of what they want
emotionally
um
wait what was the question do you think
that guys really
take seriously like because you say that
what men don't understand about women
but I'm not I'm not sure that men don't
understand that because we we understand
the emotional connection is important
right like even when it comes to sex
right that emotional connection is what
heightens the experience right
absolutely but then at the same time
in a lot of instances we really just
don't care
I think what a lot of the conversations
that women have or they're like looking
for men to care or have at least like a
basic understanding and compassion of it
and moving to in a way that I think both
sides need to
make sacrifices to help their partner
and I think that's one of them I think
there's a time and place when you know
maybe your feelings are too much and men
are like I don't care about that but I
think to completely disregard a woman's
emotions also
there's a there'll be an issue in the
relationship there you think so
I'm not focused on what a woman thinks
or what she cares about
or what she wants I'm 100 focused on me
and then it's her responsibility to be
focused on me
so if your wife came to you with an
emotional problem would you disregard
her like upfront or would you listen to
her at all like what give me an example
um say she was feeling insecure in the
relationship and she felt like she
wasn't getting enough security maybe she
thought your eye was wandering and she
was a little bit nervous about it what
would you do to comfort her or would you
just why would she be nervous about that
the nature of a guy
is to look at other women
so she was like if you understand that
then that's not something you should be
insecure about okay I think a lot of
times
you just fixed me unfortunately I'm not
as lucky as your wife to find somebody
else
she's very fortunate did you say if
you're if your wife saw that your eye is
wandering and she's worried about that
um then
then how would he react to that yeah how
would he reassure her and then you're
saying Anton that if your wife saw your
eye wandering she should not be worried
about that I think that the thing about
it is just that if you want a
relationship you understand that
you're not the only woman on the face of
the Earth right so when she says
wandering oh my God okay I'm sorry I
actually thought like a medical I wonder
yeah
I was like wait a minute
she has a lazy eye and she's like can
you please out of nowhere yeah
yeah but I mean if if you saying
wandering you know you got to be dive a
little bit more into it right is it just
is it looking at another girl or
whatever or is it no I think people
should like I think everyone looks at
other people it's what you do what's the
actions you take Okay so let's say that
was a bad example let's say you a girl's
in your DM she's sliding in the DMS and
you're responding to her you're sending
her nudes
all the way in
is this common
attorney I can tell you that it happens
[Laughter]
no you're just you're just jamming
did you get any tips on how to send one
yourself
as attorneys we're be to we can enter
into a process called Discovery where I
can ask for let's say three to five
years of your taxes your bank statements
but I can also get your DMs I can get
your tweets I can get your emails uh we
also hire private detectives and they'll
follow you around and they'll get
photographs of you and we get a lot of
information there's a lot of infidelity
going on
um Facebook actually changed the game
all the divorce attorneys remember when
Facebook really hit because you had
people reuniting uh with their old high
school sweethearts and high school
flings and colleges I mean Facebook was
one of the best things that ever
happened to divorce attorneys because we
would walk in before social media yeah
we would walk into court with just
stacks of IMS instant messages holy [ __ ]
and confessing all of what they were
doing for the past three months and all
you got me pregnant oh I'll pay 500 of
the abortion you know got the whole
right there oh my God what if your venmo
transactions are public and your lawyer
goes through your venmo and then you see
what [ __ ] is he sending money to what
how so if the person has their Instagram
it's like
like they what if they just don't share
their password
you can request that and they they are
obligated uh under Court powers to give
you that information so if you plan on
getting a divorce make sure you plan it
out three to five years ahead of time
you need to plan it out all right
absolutely
so you get a cheating clause in your
prenup a cheating clothes in your Arena
that might I mean here's the thing it's
not illegal to cheat anyway right and so
if a cheating clause in your prenup it I
guess it just depends on what the
cheating Clause is gonna say
um because people cheat all the time and
sometimes they get punished for it
sometimes they don't so they just I
guess depend on what you want to happen
if your spouse is caught cheating oh I
have a question do you think that as a
divorce attorney can cheating be
overcame in a relationship
yes absolutely uh on both ends like for
men and for women yes it's harder for
men
women can get over cheating a lot easier
than men for men it's very very
difficult interesting
um man you know it's it's kind of it's
kind of interesting how women in this
country
through history have been played to be
played out to be the more romantic
couple yeah but you see as a divorce
attorney you know I've been doing this
for 20 years it is actually the opposite
men are the real Romantics and so when
uh a woman will find out that her
husband is cheating she'll be very hurt
she'll be very disappointed she'll be
very skeptical
um but there's a part in her that name
is like well you know he's a God he
makes a lot of money this and that
whereas on the other hand with the man I
mean it's just total devastation yeah
it's the man that was like oh well she
really was beautiful you know I guess
she could have got that extra thick no
that never occurs to a man a man is like
no she loves me I love her I've been
paying the mortgage you know I've been
paying her car I've been getting her
nails done her toes done the eyelashes
how could she cheat on me when I'm
providing so much right do you think
there's a difference like
do rich and poor men get cheated on the
same or no do rich so if you had if you
had like 50 clients like they were
wealthy and 50 you know maybe maybe the
poor ones couldn't really afford you so
you don't know
about 50 clients that are poor like
would you say like they get equally
cheated on
um
a great question you know I've
represented so many men who were poor
and they got cheated on and then so many
men who were rich and they got cheated
on
um but also you can have poor men who
are married to this woman and the woman
knows that she's poor and they're not
living right and she'll be faithful to
that man and similarly you can have a
man who's making you know
30 million dollars and the wife is
faithful so I'm sure along some lines
income has something to do with it but
at the end of the day it's going to
depend much more on the personality of
the woman
what do you think the main reason is
that women cheat for like the people
that you see
oh is there like a like a particular
pattern of why they're doing it
I would say it's usually based on their
personality you know if you have a woman
that is more disagreeable and more open
to new experiences uh that's a dangerous
combination for a man to have you know
some some women just like variety right
and men don't normally think about it in
in those terms because men want to think
about love and this and that but men
often forget that that women are humans
like they're just like us right some men
uh are not fit for example for the
institution of marriage because they
love variety way too much and no matter
how much they love that woman and no
matter how many mortgage payments they
pay they are going to cheat and with
women a lot of times it's the same way
now a woman will will rationalize it
will say oh well you weren't
communicating with me enough or or you
know I'm not happy anymore or you're
neglecting me they'll come up with a lot
of reasons but
at the end of the day you know it's very
difficult for a woman for a man to
really ascertain the exact reason why
his particular woman cheated but you
know it's certainly based on personality
it's also based on circumstance if your
wife has a work husband oh
I hope your man has a work wife also
like these work spouses amazing
they are so dangerous so so dangerous do
the work spouses
end up like stealing the man ever the
woman vice versa like did will they
leave the relationship for them or they
just get like they're just trouble
I mean a lot of times the work spouses
have spouses oh right so if I if if we
are work spouses you have your spouse at
home I have my spouse at home you know
it's it can be that your spouse finds
out about me man I mean leaving my wife
all right and so it gets very very
complicated but uh you don't typically
see work spouses leaving their spouses
and then coming together you don't you
don't typically do you think they're
just oh sorry I was gonna say I feel
like with work work wives and work
husbands there's more of like an
emotional thing going on like you're at
work you're not going to be [ __ ] and
if you are then good luck keeping your
job but uh it's usually like oh so I had
a problem with my wife back home and
then the man comes in and like confides
in you I've had men do that when I used
to work in sales and they'd complain
about their girlfriends it's like
they're looking for that almost
emotional support to feel validated and
vice versa women do the same thing
um there were pillow talking not pillow
not sexting or anything like um no
pillow talking meaning
they didn't separate their personal
relationship from what it was that they
was dealing with when they were dealing
with you
more so I feel like when you have like a
work spouse like a lot of the time you
go to that person for the emotional
issues that you're facing in your
relationship so you'll go in and be like
oh she's not having sex with me or oh
he's not treating me this way or
providing in that way so you're going to
them for their [ __ ] you should actually
be going to your husband or wife for
yeah yeah but yeah that's that great but
it doesn't start out that way it always
kind of starts out with like a
friendship you know because usually
these work spouses they've been working
together for months if not years yeah so
a lot of times it doesn't start out I
mean there might be some physical
attraction but this is not how it starts
out so hey do you want to go to lunch
you know oh we've got this uh project
this deadline we might have to work
until eight o'clock and you know month
after month now they're friends and so
of course friends are going to tell each
other about problems that they have
going on at home but because now they're
disclosing private information they
start to build this bond this trust and
now they start to look at each other
with different eyes yeah and so we just
had it can happen very gradually but you
know the bond that they share can be
super all a lot of times especially
pre-pandemic when everybody was working
in the offices you could see you could
really spend more quality time with your
work spouse than your real spouse you
know if you get home at six six thirty
then you got the kids and you got dinner
and then get the kids ready you know you
might not spend any quality time with
your spouse until 8 39 9 o'clock and
then you're in bed trying to wake up
early the next morning whereas you spent
all that time uh Monday through Friday
in the office going to lunch outside of
the office sometimes going to dinner
going for drinks happy hour so you're
spending more quality time with your
work spouse than your real spouse so
it's no surprise that people start
developing attractions uh relationships
uh caring for for the people that they
work with because they spend so much
quality time with those people and it's
it's not just quality time it's like
happy quality time it's Quality quality
time because when you're at home with
your spouse sorry and you have kids
there are issues there are fights that
are coming up but when you're with that
person and you're just like oh I'm happy
like I can just be here I can be me so
you feel like you I feel like it is more
cheating than even having sex with
somebody because you're giving so much
of like that good side of you that the
person at home doesn't get I could
absolutely be the case he had a lot of
emotional disclosure a lot of sharing uh
that can be much more personal than
what's going on in let's say a 13-year
marriage where you know you're here and
she's there and y'all are living in the
same house and raising these kids but
you know after 13 years let's be honest
nobody's feeling butterflies when you
walk in the door right I do
I absolutely do how do you keep that
alive 100 I think that but no I think uh
no no I absolutely do because
it's the fact that I don't spend so much
time up under her
how long y'all been married uh 18 years
so you're saying after 18 years when
your wife walks in the door you feel
better when I walk in the door wow oh
when you walk into her she feels better
lives absolutely oh but because she's
yawning like a lot of stuff
about it like I could be gone
for a week out of town taking care of
business whatever so on and so forth
right like I don't believe that spouses
need to spend an extended amount of time
with each other
um it's almost toxic if they spend two
because because like even in a situation
at least described right and that they
become work you know work husband work
wife whatever so on and so forth they
only seeing the best of each other yeah
exactly you know what I'm saying they
don't really get to see that other side
of her because first of all she's
putting herself together and okay
let's let's really break it down right
if a guy can't recognize that a woman is
cheating
and that she's doing all of this extra
she's taking care of herself more as a
result of being you know emotionally
connected to a person because she's
trying to impress him and all of this
other type of stuff yeah those are red
flags like that's a flag that you should
see immediately that's a and then B
she's only giving them the presentation
later even though they're they're
bonding and they're they're connected
he don't really get to see the side of
her
you only get to see the best of it
and so she get to go home right he's
still sending her home so even though
it's a bond
it's not a real it's not a real thing as
to whether or not you can actually spend
the rest of your life with that person
or you can lay next to him every night
because you don't get to see the
entirety of who she truly is
so that's why when people wind up
cheating with each other and let's just
say they wind up getting together or you
know they leave their spouse or this one
is single and he leave his spouse for
her
it sometimes don't work out or more
often than not it won't work out because
the same issue she's still carrying
herself into the next relationship she's
not gonna change with that dude she just
gave him the best ever and then when he
got a chance to see the entirety of of
who she really is
it's like oh okay I want to the next one
which all Lee told me was that some
people should not get married like I'm
not an advocate for married for marriage
for everybody I don't think that
everybody is built for marriage I think
that there's a formula for how to be
successful in marriage right which takes
you know a level of discipline I think
that it's other factors that you have to
take into consideration I think marriage
is a business first before it is love I
don't think that anybody should lead
with love when they're trying to get
married I think that the foundation of
marriage has to be much deeper than that
but everybody is not built for it and so
I don't know why people advocate for
everybody to get married
when in reality I think that people
would be much more successful there's a
lot of people that would be much more
successful both in relationships and in
a regular life if they truly embraced
who they really were instead of trying
to embrace what Society is pushing on
yeah that's deep but let's get back to
the whole butterflies thing
so let me let me get this right because
I didn't know if I picked up on some
asymmetry there are you saying that when
you walk in the door after 18 years your
wife feels butterflies but when she
walks in the door after 18 years you do
not feel butterfly no I'm excited to get
home I'm excited though I want to know
about the butterflies do you feel
butterflies it's not butterflies for
guys it's butterflies for women however
I am very excited to get home
and I love my bed like I love laying
next to my chair we sleep a certain type
of way you know what I'm saying like
I gotta be the big spoon you know what
I'm saying like I mean ever the little I
know I'm not but I thought it'd make it
a little too but here's the thing it's
not even about like sex or anything like
that it's more about like the habits
that we've built you know what I'm
saying like I'm used to seeing my
daughter when I get home when I might be
out of town on Friday come in and she
say a specific thing when I walk in the
door and then we reserve Sundays because
I work so much during the week just for
family time like I'm excited for that
because that's something that I don't
get to get to see on a regular basis
which I believe that absence does make
the heart grow fonder and if a dude
really want to start loving his chick a
little bit more he need to get from up
under her and stop spending so much time
always up under her stop working from
home go work somewhere else go hang out
with the fellas go do some other stuff
that actually add value into your life
so you have a chance for her to miss you
that's huge yeah yeah exactly right
you're nodding you guys agree with that
oh absolutely absolutely do you see a
guy too much just annoy you ah it's
almost like why do you have so much time
to see me I definitely want to feel are
you from am I what no I'm saying like
you're thinking are you a bum yeah
do you have goals are you building
towards something I do you think the hot
like absence makes the heart grow fonder
I have been in long-distance
relationships though and I think absence
made his dick hard for other women so
but that's kind of the same thing though
because you do say you'll say well you
know you'll ask in your head you know
why are you spending so much time here
you know why why aren't you busy but
with guys we always get the whole you
know why aren't you home more right why
don't you have so much time to spend
with me why are you going to the game
you know why don't you do this with me
why don't you die to me so women at
women are asking for the thing that
might kind of diminish the relationship
because they're asking for so much time
with you and then when you give it to
them they're like why are you here I
think it's really important about the
type of time that you're giving them
like just hanging out every day it
doesn't really mean much that's not
building something like you're setting
apart a full day for your family you're
putting intention behind that like
everyone's looking for that like forward
to that every week it keeps you like
everyone excited and in on it you know
whereas if it was just the monogamous
like we're together every day we're
doing the exact same thing he's working
from home I'm working from home whatever
it may be then that time was where you
get annoyed you start like it's almost
like when you have a roommate and you're
around too long like we've been in
fights because we traveled together and
we did so much together it was like we
need space in order for us to have a
healthy friendship and I think that same
thing applies to relationships as well
any of the girls I see I see it all the
time
um a lot of girls and guys let me like
let's say on it like they go on a couple
dates and then they spend like five days
together really soon in the relationship
I think that completely destroys
the healthy like the that even becoming
a relationship I feel like the
relationships that start and they're
just together all the time like from the
jump you know it's gonna end quick yeah
you started the whatever starts quick
ends quick yeah what I really like about
what Anton said is like he's having
friendships outside of the relationship
he has Hobbies he's pouring into himself
like Jamie said with the intention like
he's intentionally spending time with
his family they're doing stuff together
but he's also making sure that he's
taking care of himself and I think the
women that are like why aren't you
spending time with me why aren't you
more with me like they're anxious or
they're anxiously attached to that man
because they don't have a lot going for
them and if they were focusing on
themselves if they were working out if
they were building Hobbies they wouldn't
feel so anxious and like they have to
cling to that person and constantly be
spending time with them to get the love
that they need because they'd be giving
that love to themselves well I mean she
needs to yearn for me you know right
like yeah oh absolutely absolutely she
needs to
she it has to be a balance for her but
it doesn't have to be a balance for me
right so I'm gonna focus on doing what I
do right I'm gonna go out I'm a build
I'm gonna do [ __ ]
um you know I'm a travel I'm a do you
know take care of business the majority
of my day is going to be taken up with
you know stuff that has to do with
making money
like that's what guys do they do stuff
they make money and then they do stuff
to take care of themselves right
but then at the same time obviously you
need to have a you know some stuff that
you do whether you're going to the gym
or you know you're hanging out you know
with your mom I don't care what you do
right
you need to figure out what makes sense
for you and then
Focus
she should naturally be focused on me it
shouldn't be something that I have to
force her to do right so like for
example my wife
she was like yo
I don't even want to work for nobody
else I just want to work for you
right and so I'm like oh okay cool well
you know we'll figure out what that
looked like and she's really really
great at what it is that she does but it
still doesn't mean that she can be under
me 24 hours a day like she might travel
with me you know what I'm saying she
here but she flew in a day after I flew
in because I had to take care of some
business and she don't she don't focus
on what it is that I'm doing she just
focused on the value that she can add to
me
so what why what are common mistakes you
see you know the single women making
nowadays with with relationships or just
in general well just in general because
like the marriage rate is so low now
like it's lower than it's ever been so
you know single women think that they
men they think that they can do the same
thing as men they think that they can
have is just as many bodies they think
that they can sleep with just as many
people and not have the same effect
because see like a guy a guy can sleep
with a chick and we're not talking about
the dudes that get emotionally attached
right but we can we can sleep with a
chicken not even remember your name the
minute that we have pulse not clarity
like the very millisecond the mindset
can be now how do I get her out of here
you know what I'm saying like it doesn't
have to be an emotional attachment now a
woman in a lot of instances she can't
because she's being inserted right you
can't unsee and not take with you all of
the dudes that and and how that dude
affected you into a relationship so they
think that they can just do the same
thing as men and not be affected when in
reality
you are because you really carry in all
of this trauma and all of this stuff
that comes along with being in a
previous relationship and every other
relationship and she can't see it even
if it's subconscious she can't see the
experiences that she's already had so
you can't operate like a man do you guys
think
do you think that women
um
I don't remember it was like do women
fall in love through sex
or yeah like or do women fall in love
for like a guy that's more of a provider
or guy that just offers good sex I think
nowadays
women get blinded by good sex and they
think it's love but it's not have you
seen the Titanic woman always been doing
this yeah for sure
the notebook I think the idea is when
you have both then you're really in love
then it's game over Lord knows I've been
dignitized but
it does not lead to a sustainable
relationship as dignitized you've ever
been or you don't want to know
[Applause]
I was so dignitized that uh first of all
we broke up 20 times in one year I would
go back and be like please take me back
I was such a little [ __ ] [ __ ]
he was like you have to wear a mask and
come over so I'd come over after the
drive during the pandemic you'd be like
you couldn't come near me without a mask
so I would mask up and he'd be like suck
my dick and I'd be like okay and I would
take the mask off and then I put the
mask back on and I would ride his dick
into the [ __ ] sunset with a mask on
yeah so I've been dignitized no no where
is he now is he still in the picture he
is sending me dick pics trying to get me
back and like progress photos of his
workouts yeah oh okay he can get her if
you want her
I think the biggest thing was though
most of them had toxic behaviors and
both so that was not allowing them to
have like to grow their connection and
they need time apart to heal that I
don't know I was just thinking why why
did he blocked he could have her
that's a good point oh that's true you
didn't block him I didn't I did tell you
to block him I've never gonna block him
he's not she's got the door's got to be
open a little bit he can get her he can
get her tomorrow if you wanted her
fun fact about Emily and I'm gonna put
you on the Emily's been celibate for
over a year and a half since that
boyfriend
wow oh my God that's what they say that
the women get their hearts broke and
then they go celibate yeah yeah I did it
for eight months after like my dramatic
relationship and I think that completely
changed the game for me emotionally like
growing as a woman because I definitely
was
the girl who used almost like sex in my
body to feel validated by men like that
was the only way I'd feel close to
somebody and I misconstrued it for what
it was but being celibate has like
allowed me to like okay who is this man
for real you talk about like marriage
being like a business I used to just be
like in love and be like okay I love you
let's get married and have babies but if
there wasn't things that I was thinking
about ahead of time that would make sure
that it was a fulfilling long-term
relationship how can you decide though
that it's fulfilling long-term
relationship if the guy
is not having sex because if the guy is
worth anything and he's not having sex
he's not going to stay with you right oh
this isn't like we're not having sex
when we're with men this is when we
weren't dating if I'm with my man we're
having sex
he's gonna be taken care of him
right yeah yeah it's like I think part
of the being celibate too is like I was
spending time dating and I
was having sex and I was having sex with
the wrong people and like when they
weren't like showing me they deserved it
as much and from that there I mean like
they were still taking care of sexually
but
the relationship building blocks were
not there how does a guy show that he
deserve it
um I think you can kind of tell now I'm
able to tell when a man is a little bit
more serious it's like how they reach
out to you how they respect you are they
opening doors are they introducing you
to meet their family are they but are
they doing that like at the right time
they're like hey it's important for
someone to meet my Mom they're not just
letting everyone meet their mom you know
what I mean
um their values and what they're working
on there's a lot of aspects it's pretty
nuanced that's the determining factor
for whether or not you can have sex with
you or it's just like if he's
relationship material
why don't you tell us what do you think
I mean I don't
ever but I mean other people got it
already though
what do you mean so you think a woman
should sleep with a man right away
why should I wait well you don't have to
wait but are you going to respect the
woman the same amount respect her how
it's an equal extent you getting
somebody that's just like I am so if you
want a girl to be like that relationship
material should she wait to have sex
with you
well I mean but you've already you've
already given it away yeah it's like
it's like insulting to guys if you make
them wait but you didn't make the last
like you let the last five hit like I
want the same thing that the last guy
got it's kind of like the way the way I
make it as an equivalent is like if a
dude I don't know bought you a
let's just say 100 gift and then you
found out the year before he planned his
girlfriend a whole surprise party and
all this stuff yeah and you'd be like
like first you're happy with the gift
you're like oh I got this great gift and
then you find out that's what he did for
the last girl and you're like I feel
like a lot of men don't appreciate
things they don't work for though as
much and like women Bond through having
sex like that hormones released but men
bond in the time of like they're not
having sex and getting to know somebody
then they have sex and they're a little
bit more locked in because they've taken
the time to get to know someone versus
when you just hit it right away you're
like well I already got what I was
looking for and you're not taking that
time to like fully invest in something I
think I think you're right I just think
like to a lot of times to guys it's it's
just insulting to them if you let the
guy a guy before have sex right away and
then later you make someone else I mean
because we already know yeah that you
let the guy or at least previous guys so
what about what if
um so for me personally the guys who
I've had sex with they have had to wait
so do you think that moving forward I
should just have sex right now have you
had sex with a lot of guys no they had
to wait like six months
oh that's a long time
I think like
almost when I was much younger as I've
gotten older I think it's the time has
speak okay like the last guy the last
guy he wait
he waited probably two months two three
months around there too
man this guy wait two three months I
just want to get this job and you said
wait
well she's young right so I think 24. oh
oh okay it's your baby wait no but my
question you can I say that the only
fans yeah isn't it
you made the guy wait two three months
you only fans so I actually didn't do
only fans at that time I was running
martial arts studios in the the North
Shore of Massachusetts back then but
regardless I think even though I do only
fans I would try to see how a guy treats
me like I personally think if a guy is
touching you a lot in the first couple
of dates he doesn't respect you and he
views you more in a sexual Manner and
he's not looking for a long term that's
one of the red flags that I look out for
I just like once you kind of open the
only fans box like a guy's gonna be
insulted if you make him wait that long
having sex on only fans if you're like
[ __ ] for money and then you're not
[ __ ] the guy then that's different if
you're just like
I don't know do it what can I see on
your own events like what am I saying
for me personally
um I I don't have sex on my only fans I
will show some like ex like explicit
content of my body but I don't really
show a lot
but I could see you naked though right
and the same for you yeah I do a lot of
what it's because I was a comedian I
actually started only fans
um after the relationship how we met
um and to do a topless comedy shows so I
was like I was like how do I make money
the pandemic was happening I was a sales
rep in marketing the first thing people
are ditching is their marketing budgets
and I was like I'm gonna owe all this
money back and I'm no longer gonna be
making six figures I need to figure
something out and I always wanted to do
social media and I viewed it as a tool
to make money so I didn't take my
underwear off for the first like eight
months and I did topless comedy shows I
did a lot of like dirty talk videos
where I'm like instructing you but I
could be fully clothed just talking so I
was trying to find the Avenues of giving
someone a sexual experience without
actually like fully exposing everything
I think I got sucked into the industry
and it is a very hard industry did not
get sucked into when you're surrounded
by a bunch of people doing stuff and I
think I did cross the line that I
thought I was cool with at the time and
wasn't and so I've like tried to scale
back but like twerking videos I'm doing
a dance and I have like a robot and then
I like go down to my laundry and it's
like or I'm talking dirty or
right
but I'm saying like why should I respect
why is a guy supposed to respect you
more than
you respect yourself
on camera which is cold like listen I'll
do the only fans I think that everybody
got a place in society you know what I'm
saying I'm not trying to control
everybody
listening
from doing what they want to do I think
that everybody can see what they want to
do if you want to [ __ ] around or you
want to do this you want to cool
whatever I don't care about that all I'm
saying is why do I have to be more
respectful
you don't you absolutely don't but I'm
saying why do you have a standard he's
explaining this is just how men why do
you have a higher standard for the guy
but everybody else can see it
so for whatever the price is yeah I
totally understand that and absolutely
and it sounds like if you were single
and I was single we would not be aligned
and we would not work together and
that's totally okay I also understand
that having an only fans does uh make
the dating pool smaller just like how
you were talking about how only 20 of
men are actually attractive to women I'm
sure not the same amount applies to men
who are attracted to only fans but okay
but you're looking to get married one
day though right yeah
and you're gonna keep your only fans no
I hope not so you so you only holding on
to the only fans until you get married
so I don't plan on sticking with only
fans for long this is like Jamie said a
stepping stone where we're using it to
build towards other things like we're
building the podcast but she's building
her comedy career yeah it's just a
stepping stone like with my doing only
fans like growing up
um
I guess poor and where Financial
struggles were really big I grew up on
welfare and fuel assistance prior to
that I grew up in a very rich like
Jewish household and we lost it all
um so Financial Security has been really
important to me and uh I mean listen I'm
for it like pop that [ __ ] yeah
and that's not everything I'm not listen
do that get it get your money do all of
that all I'm saying is
the the price of the brick is is lower
than y'all probably think it is like do
y'all so y'all saying that a guy is
supposed to come through knowing that
y'all got the only fans we could see it
everybody can see it because I value my
chick well not everyone because the
value that I have on my check is based
off of the fact yeah that's what I'm
trying to say what's the brick what's
the what's the price it actually it uh
it different girls self things for
different some people sell porn gang
bangs for 2.29.
I started with a 30 sub monthly
subscription price and then on my page
there was everything was like basically
a spicy Instagram page
thirty dollars I made 20 grand in my
first one subscriber yeah she had a it's
only fans and hers was like three
dollars yeah so I think a lot of people
undervalue that and part of the way it
grew uh blew up on Tick Tock is I was
teaching girls how to make money and my
biggest thing was sex sales personality
sells more and like the more you
withhold the less you do like the more
they're like they want to buy AI to see
and they're always like wondering what
else they can see so I was teaching
girls like don't show anything if you're
gonna show stuff don't do it right away
like ease people into it so that you
have like you can make money so if you
have an acute 24 year old girl and she
wants to start early fans how much can
she anticipate making like how do in
terms of a business in general it really
depends on what she's willing to do if
is she willing to Market herself like is
she willing to really go ham and promote
herself on a tick tock Twitter primarily
Tick Tock how can you spot ourselves as
the podcast so like if you go to our
social media we do talk about sexual
stuff that kind of gets people in and
where it's open but we're doing comedy
videos stand up
um collabs on like comedy sketches the
podcast all of that traffic the more
traffic we get the more people are
funneled to our page I
don't agree with like promoting only
fans and just being like subscribed to
my only fans I think playing like the
long game where people are like oh wait
she has only fans and doesn't expect it
but y'all sell sex though right
yeah I guess yeah I'm selling six right
I think a lot of the conversations that
I have with men personally they're not
at they're not like insecure about it or
they're like they're totally open to it
yeah
oh absolutely but I think that there's a
lot of men who are like in relationships
that I've heard that talk about it and
they're like get your bag dude I'm
comfortable with what it is and a lot of
them what do you think they gonna tell
you what do you think they're gonna tell
you listen babe I'm insecure
um
that bothers me like what do you think
that they're gonna tell you they telling
you what you want to hear in order for
you to be able to do what you need them
to do yeah some don't some are very like
don't do if you're gonna date me you
can't do only fans
and I'm like are you gonna supplement
that income so I can get away take me
away from all this I I would be happy
and I like I don't want to have to do it
but it's the fact that I get to travel I
get to do what I want we're growing the
podcast my brother was struggling with
homelessness for like the last year and
I took my savings from only fans and I
moved him down here got in an apartment
and gave him like a safe space that now
he can grow and build and I think that
that's like a really beautiful thing and
I would rather be able to have that help
my family grow myself
no I'm saying a guide I could take you
away from that
I'm looking for him he can buy your
freedom right you'll provide a provider
I mean we could put the label on or
whatever but you know he can buy them I
don't know right right he frees you from
having to do that so then so then you
become yeah well the goal is that
hopefully the podcast replaces that
income and then we don't have to do it
and then I'm moving forward having
conversations with men that are much
different
can't erase
the only fans content though right that
I've done in the past no
yeah I mean it's not like um I just I
feel like it's not for everyone and I
don't think all women should do it I
feel like only fans has a place in
society this is an unpopular opinion in
his place but it's just like this is how
men think even the guys that say they're
okay with it like I was talking to
adam22 you know and he was saying how um
I mean only fans is different than porn
but you're saying like all the porn
stars he knows the boyfriends will start
off being like Oh I'm okay with it and
then later like down the road they break
either they want like a cut of the money
or they want they want to restrict what
they do and I think that's a
conversation I think some people do why
do they want to cut the money because
they're actually participating in it
like in the videos and stuff either both
and just because they're like well if my
girl's doing it and you're making money
off of it then I want to make money off
your body too they watch the Andrew Tate
video yeah yeah exactly anyway so let's
say I meet a girl and I and we're dating
and then she tells me on the third date
she's like Hey listen Lead You Know by
the way you know I got this only fans
popping you know life is hard I had to
get it out the mud I'd be like okay so
then six dates in I'm like hey you know
I've been taking you out to dinner
what's up with a cutter the only fans
like how is that is that how it is some
guys view like you selling your body as
selling their body so they're like if
you're selling my body and it's they're
talking about you then I should deserve
a cut because that's my girl my body but
it's like okay my ex would write out the
psycho dramas like so you know how like
the beginning of a porn scene they have
like a story line and the pizza man
comes and delivers it like some people
really care about that and if you can
build up like a storyline that makes it
seem like it's not and then they they're
more likely to open the private message
that's paid for so you send like some
freedoms he would come up with like the
marketing strategy of all right we're
gonna go here and this is what you're
gonna do and he'll write out like the
script and have everything ready and he
would like film for me and like do that
and he'd set up and he like loved it and
he's like no you're fine and I was like
all right cool PS5 for your birthday I
was like you want a pair of J's what do
you want babe like thank you for
participating and helping me and like
supporting me
I know it's weird but no you're really
sorry
you're selling yourself short in what
way
I think you under the wrong tutelage I
really do the one wrong what tutelage I
think that you need to nah that's a
whole another conversation no no
question oh I have a question I don't
know about the right tutelage yeah me
too
I think that what is tulips I know I'm
not thinking
I believe that you can be a lot more
successful and I think that you're
probably selling yourself short I I'm
not really sure that you got the right
guidance I think that if you had the
right guidance and the right person
um
where did she get she got 20K the first
time you said 20K the first month I had
5 000 I had 5 000 Instagram followers 2
000 Twitter followers and that's it
but the reason I was able to make so
much money I think is because I played
the role like I'm a comedian and you
typically wouldn't see this and then you
have I spent a hundred dollars for a
five minute Tom like topless comedy set
like I'm in shorts and just my boobs are
out and I'm like telling jokes to the
camera and people were buying it I got
recognized by a huge comedian as a
result I had articles written about it
as being like a comedian only fans I
took all of that free time that I was
able to provide myself and I was like
you're [ __ ] up in the head like you
got a lot to work on yourself I'm gonna
take this time to heal and like do
therapy and figure out what my value is
as a person because I don't think when I
decided to do only fans that I was a
secure human person like I wasn't secure
in myself in a lot of ways and I think
it provided a opportunity for me to not
be so worried about money because I was
in sales I was doing the corporate job I
had brown hair I dressed conservatively
like I did all of that and I was
hustling and busting my ass I was like I
can't do this and struggle and I wasn't
able to get out of the financial hole
that I was in from college so it just
gave me that opportunity and so I think
I would love for a person and then my
person who I would eventually marry to
look at all of the work that I've done
as a result and not completely dismiss
me because of doing only fans so I had a
question when you're struggling for
money
you guys are pretty girls what made you
guys go the only fans route and not the
gold digger out
just feeling like if I was in that
situation I feel like I would go the
gold digger out you know like sugar
daddy not sugar daddy I I'd be like okay
this is what I was thinking I went to
box seats the other day Okay my dad his
friend had box seats we went to like
this is very like these you know what
box seats are yeah yeah it's very
expensive they're all rich right and I
was thinking there's a girl that happens
doing the cart for the desserts this
girl was so heavy right she was so fat
and I was just like that is a waste of
an opportunity
that's what I was thinking
I was running out of money yeah I would
I would have been the only fans around
I'm going to wear the high value matter
I would be like that's like the golf
cart girls I talked to this guy the
other day but um there's like one of my
one-on-one sessions and he was telling
me like sometimes people just like want
to tell you stories on one-on-one set I
don't know it was interesting but he was
telling me he's like girls going through
the wrong Rich guys to go after the
managers when the owners are the ones
like they're average guys at these
places no girls really talk to them and
he's like they're worth like 60 to 70
million I'm like if I had to choose I
gotta just go that route
[Music]
I just feel like like you get a job
that's the bar cart girl you're in the
same room as all the guys worth 60
million yeah it's not like that's that
hard of a job to get bar cart girl yeah
how are you going to get the 20 000 in
in 30 days
[Music]
I think
where I was at because of uh emotionally
like my trauma and all of that I
actually looked older and I I think I'm
like more in my Prime now than when I
was younger like I looked tired and worn
out and beat down like you could see
that like the world was wearing on me
and I don't think like the energy that I
was putting out was conducive for me
finding like someone like that I wasn't
until now that I'm like okay like I can
dress like a lady I like know how to
hold myself and have like those
conversations because only fans allowed
me to have that time to myself
um and now I'm in those rooms where I'm
starting to like meet those men and talk
to that but when I had no money I didn't
have any money to buy nice clothes to
like buy a nice dress and and have the
time off all right you can't give up 20
000 a month yeah so I actually I went on
a date with like I don't know you could
turn him as a sugar daddy I met him at
like a rich bar in Boston like in Back
Bay and he was like I want to take you
out and I was like okay like this guy's
in a nice area like why not try the
sugar daddy route that's when it was
really being pushed on social media I
feel like
he was probably 40 but I was also 19. so
like I was like oh he's so old like he
must have so much money and then we went
on a date he took me to a shitty [ __ ]
restaurant I was like oh this dude's got
no money his Volvo had to busted out
headlight I was like oh man I cannot
choose or sugar daddy ever you cannot
choose them but how did you determine
that he was a sugar daddy just as he was
40. were you on a site I didn't know I
just guessed I was like oh he probably
has money like you know he was in like
the financial district I go there he's
like yeah I want to have sex with no
condom I'll give you a hundred bucks and
I was like
a little sugar dating I was like no
thank you I'm so good I I really value
like connection like I really want to
like feel connected so like the money
can't be the only thing a hundred
dollars for raw sex you got me [ __ ] up
so what was the number okay what was the
right number then for real sex
what was the right number 200.
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
no I'm just kidding
she's getting 2 000.
the right number now after I think only
fans did make me feel more secure in
myself and I feel a lot more confident
now I swear if you saw the change in
like my photos and videos and how I
carried myself and not like even the
only fan stuff I'm not gonna I would say
the world that only fans is able to
provide yeah but like just like regular
[ __ ] that I would post on social media I
feel a lot more confident and I don't
know where I was going with this you
just been able to actually actually okay
wait this I don't think
that time to grow though it's our
question did you know before you started
only fans that like people might look at
you a certain way yes yeah okay yeah
that was I think a lot of people in the
month you're like so I was so when I
started it I was like okay the pandemic
is gonna be the day I had like broken up
with the boyfriend and moved in with
Emily that day pandemic started like the
lockdown and that's when like the
finance stuff was happening and I ended
up getting like discriminated against
um in my company by like my new sales
manager and some one of my ex-best
friends got mad I was making more money
than her in sales and went to my boss
and was like she as an only fans
and so I went through like basically a
legal battle with my company for a
couple months and I was like this isn't
Gonna Last the job Market's gonna be
hard my friend who had like no so she's
like I made 700 like why don't you just
try it you don't have to do anything and
I was like you know what like I won't
show any like show that much you didn't
have an only fans no during this time
and so I was just when I was deciding to
start it and I was looking at it I was
like okay I'll do it for three months
I'll become like the comedian on only
fans who does like topless comedy I'll
get the marketing out of that I'll get a
boost in my income and I'll take that
time to look for another job and like be
in Corporate America but something like
deep down was like you don't want to be
in Corporate America well yeah the money
that you made said that you didn't want
to be in Corporate America
like 17 000 commission checks from being
in sales so like you have to hump it
though yeah it was it was so stressful
and so I was like wow I'm doing a court
like a fraction of the work and I'm
making money and once I started making
like good money I was like oh
I took that as like you have to dive in
because I sold marketing but see I know
y'all can't ever talk to a regular guy
again all right
I think there's a lot of regular guys
are okay do I think like the ones that
are yours I want a regular guy right
but see she being uh she sees me unreal
you can't talk you can't talk to a
regular guy I don't know right but what
woman wants a regular guy what is a
regular guy you know like a guy that
makes I gotta make sixty thousand
dollars a year once kids you know 401K
you don't want that guy no I don't think
I ever wanted guy who is only making
sixty thousand dollars what's that
what's the minimum threshold
I don't know because for me it depends a
lot on personality oh no yeah
so when he says the number you're like
oh well it's personality that's true the
guy's making 60 also had a personality
all right you got me so those guys are
the good ones but if we're okay if we're
in media and are like we're doing that
we're you already need like a certain
type of man that's gonna handle it with
you being online and all the time only
fans aside so if you're a social media
what do we need to make that they just
need to be an entrepreneur
okay so what's my dollar limit you're
saying because I just hit the floor I
mean everything anybody like 30 million
yeah but what's the floor I'd say like
120.
around there
what about you
I would say I would want when my dad was
doing well he was making like a decent
amount and that really did help our
family and based on like my biggest
drama is like the financial stuff if
you're making 60k a year I already know
if we have say we have three kids you're
making 60k a year I'm not doing only
fans so I'm working under you you can't
one you can't pay me to work under you
that's not enough for me to take away
from having another job and then there
there's not a lot of disposable income
there if something happened we're in a
recession whatever happens saving up for
college like 60k is not a lot in terms
what's the minimum
I would say like 150
so you won 20 you won 50.
yeah so you want 150 but also you want a
guy that is going to accept your only
fans pass I think with 150 if you're an
entrepreneur you're already a little bit
more open to different ways of life even
if you're in corporate or Finance or
you're a surgeon no they are not I'll
tell you no no no I grew up in a family
of entrepreneurs they would none of them
all my brothers make six figures none of
them would take home and only fans girl
I feel like guys who are in more like
boxed in jobs
but I mean it just pins I guess like
what they're saying what's on the only
fans if if they've got content like I'm
a YouTuber right so if I'm making only
fans and I've got some private YouTube
videos that YouTube doesn't want me to
uploading because they're gonna
demonetize it right so I put it in only
fans that's one thing but you know I
started unbutting in my pants
hold up so no I mean
I mean so many other women
right that's the only thing
um for sure there are women that you
know and I'm not saying there's anything
wrong right because if you're getting 20
grand a month it's like hey man yeah you
know but that's also okay that that's
your boundary that you wouldn't want to
date a woman who has shown but also like
porn stars that have husbands right you
know what I'm saying so they I mean you
and I we talked to uh
[Laughter]
you and I talked to a YouTuber and like
he was like you know damn his marriage
right yeah that was wow yeah so you know
I want to be another secret what
happened
he was a YouTuber his name is uh Mr
Lucario a well-respected YouTuber
no no no he has a he's in a lifestyle
that's let's say he's in an open
marriage and it's okay on both sides you
know if if and they're happy right so
like more power to them right but to to
to regular guys like you know me and
Anton you know we really can't imagine
our wife going to her boyfriend's house
and then
she my wife is giving her boyfriend head
and then coming home and kissing me yeah
in her mouth because that's my wife oh
wow no yeah unless you're doing it
together like I wouldn't know even then
like together or apart there's no no
one's coming in my wife's mouth
together no no no no no no no
it's gonna work
and only fans we learn a lot I have a
lot of men more men than you think who
are in like these roles and have like
nice jobs or whatever they feel because
they can't talk to their women openly
about like their Kinks or what they want
sexually that they that will seek only
fans girls to have those conversations
and there's a lot of room but they're
not marrying the only film no but
they're dissatisfied and with the girls
that they're marrying because they're
not they're not they're not dissatisfied
sexually no see which I don't understand
about guys that's a lot of
dissatisfaction no I agree that there
are a lot of guys that are the satisfied
but it doesn't necessarily right see a
guy can have multiple different women
serving different purposes
and they don't necessarily need one
woman to do everything in order for them
to be satisfied you understand what I'm
saying yeah so there are some guys that
are in sexless marriages and stuff like
that so we're not going to ignore those
dudes right but my point is is that you
may
a dude may not want his woman to fit a
certain fetish that he may have
but he may fulfill that somewhere else
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
he's not satisfied with the role that
she's playing okay yeah so a dude can
have multiple different women fulfilling
different purposes and that's okay for
that particular guy but that doesn't
mean he's not possessive about the fact
that he don't want his girl to be with
another dude you understand what I'm
saying yes I do think that that means
that he is dissatisfied in his sexual
relationship which is all I was trying
to say or maybe he just has a robust
sexual appetite that requires multiple
different Lifestyles or different women
to fulfilled it but what if you're going
to have a woman that does all of that
his wifey and his
kinky in the way that you wanted
specifically I think that if you talk to
most men
considering that most men or a lot of
guys are in sexless marriages
I think it's very rare for a dude to
find a unicorn
why do you think a lot of men are in
sexless marriages
I think a lot of women marry their
second choice
and then they get the kids and then they
just stop wanting to have sex do you
think men marry the second choice though
like I feel like everyone every man has
their first love I [ __ ] it up she got
away and that still will always be their
number one I actually I actually agree
with you um I think a lot of guys marry
their second choice too but I just think
women like we can't really be satisfied
with our second choice third choice I'm
not sure like what do you think why do
you think Titanic was such a hit think
about it women love Titanic they love
the notebook those are two female movies
why do so many women identify with that
it's the one that got away I'm not sure
it's like the push and pull that's toxic
back and forth that you don't know if
you're gonna have them or not that keeps
people that keeps that a lot I don't
think that guys married a second choice
I think guys get married earlier
and then they evolve and grow to be
better versions of themselves whereas
the woman in a lot of instances
she's already hit her Peak and she's
going down and so it kind of is a thing
to where he's growing and evolving and
he's just now realizing his power
because he doesn't even realize that the
best version of him is way later in life
and then it it just turns into a thing I
think a lot of people get married
without actually considering who they
are and they get into these
relationships early and they don't
actually know who they are they don't
know what they want and then they get
out of relationships and they're like oh
my gosh I can blossom I can actually be
who I want to be I can actually go for
the sex that doesn't work for you that
don't work for women that doesn't work
for women
in what way because you're at your Peak
when you're younger see I feel like I'm
at my Peak now if I showed you a
transformation photo of what I looked
like I don't think I would have gotten
the time of day for a lot of people I'm
curious honestly a peak based off of
what guys desire in women
and what do men desire in women in
marriage first the first thing that they
desire is that another not a lot of guys
haven't done what they wanted okay so
exclusivity 100 yeah Anton let's let's
be real let's be real looks is first a
guy would take a guy would take okay
[Applause]
so so I got a guy's gonna take
let's say only fans corn whatever
120 over a 320 girl
320 pounds
no I I know I know there's some
variability in the middle but to get in
the door you have to have a base level
of looks higher to get in the door
that's why I said it looks his first
because if yeah that has to get you in
the door guys aren't as picky a lot of
guys though earlier that's my fate
everything a lot of guys earlier in
their life though they married a person
a day like I'm 29 close proximity too
that's just my face but I look tired I
wasn't like I don't know I just got red
hair
you think I look like that right now
don't insult me like that because you
look like tired with like no makeup like
that's what I think it like you look
better now right I think I'm like
glowing I think the way that is the
Playboy
so you like how I look
I want to see where like I would I was
heavier too and I'm five two so it
makes me pretty compact but a lot a lot
of these guys if you look at a most guys
wives
they're normal yeah you probably look
better now yeah they're just normal
girls oh for sure you don't have to I
feel like
the girls that get married sometimes are
not anything special
like look like looks wise because I
think a lot of guys want more of like
security and safety like not know
knowing their woman is picking them and
is loyal to them so I don't think looks
are as important I think when like
[ __ ] maybe I have a question why do
you think that men cheat on uglier girls
and then they'll [ __ ] and cheat with
like a six oh because she's there and
Willie
right no I I don't remember this day it
was like the day I realized I had to
worry about the ugly girls too I was
like oh my God it's hot yeah I'm almost
like if you cheat on me with like
someone who is hotter then I'm like you
know what I understand yeah like that
was tempting and maybe that's the
hottest girl you've ever been with and
that's a situation where it's like if
you're with somebody who's like actually
loving you giving you everything that
you want and then you decide to like go
[ __ ] a two for no reason and you just
like ruin your relationship like I'm
like what the hell like that hurts that
that's like itchy deep she was just like
well and that's just how men are yeah
yeah men are really not built to be
turning down blow jobs
but what if they're getting blow jobs
[Music]
okay so if you're in a relationship or
you're married and some girl walks up to
do she's like hey you want head
instinctually I'll be like yeah
right emotionally now logically I'm like
okay well let me weigh the options let
me think about it right are you gonna
tell my wife you know you have to
balance it out it's all you know you got
to make a a calculated decision but if
we're honest if a six walks up to a
man's like you know do you want to hit
there's gonna be a part of that man you
know of course right so that's something
I'll eat until you come five times I'm
gonna think about that but it's about
having the control and willpower that's
confident though confidence is awesome
20 grand right
I mean it's not even just the only fans
like I don't know you just seem like a
very sexual person so I am and I think
that uh I think that Sexual Energy
though is also Creative Energy and so it
channeling being able to control your
sexual energy and use that energy for
like creation whether it's creating a
baby a family a home art painting us
podcasting like you can Channel all that
so I think that's like what we did when
we were celibate it was like okay like
that build up of being celibate you
think it was easy no I was like a drug
addict I was like scratching being like
how the [ __ ] am I gonna go longer than
this month and then it gets easier and
then I through that gained way more
self-worth and I was able to Channel all
the energy and I was like writing comedy
and like doing things so you feel like
okay actually I was gonna ask you this
earlier you feel like they're only fans
you feel better
like about yourself
and and do you think it's fun I think
aspects of it are fun like sometimes
we'll have like parties with our friends
we'll have slumber parties and then
we'll I don't know like pillow fight
each other and like cute PJs like that's
like hanging out with your girls and
then you sell it as a video or like the
sexual stuff yeah I I don't like being
sexual unless I'm with my person and I
it's connection is super important to
you when it comes to being sexual so I
actually have a hard time making only
fans content because I don't feel sexual
same so it's it's not fun for me it is
work you guys don't enjoy the actual
like making the content I think when I
was with my ex and it was like a thing
that we did together and we like got to
like put our creative juices together it
was like I felt like I had like more
meaning behind what I was doing and like
less about just like money and like you
know and so that I really totally I
enjoyed it with doing it with him she
needs the tutelage I'm just trying to
tell you and I I don't like like it's
hard for me to make content like I don't
think I've made new content in like the
past month because I've been busy and
I'm like [ __ ] the last thing I want to
do is like wear my tits out on camera
and stuff but I think there are aspects
that are fun I think when I first
started and I had this new lifestyle of
like traveling and we do like content
houses
um with like girls so we'll just like go
to Mexico with all of our friends like
have an Airbnb we're taking pictures by
the pool we're creating content we're
hanging out like that was very fun and
that I feel fulfilled when I'm home by
myself and now I have to like try to
come up with something to sell I'm like
oh this is so annoying and I can't wait
to like make money elsewhere well
because just I feel like a lot of times
when girls are in like sex industries
they'll come back later and say oh um
like I was used and like the industry
like used me and I just find that like
during they're like fine with it so
that's what I was asking no I feel I
feel used during like I'm using my body
yeah yeah it definitely it wears on you
men mentally and I don't think a lot of
people talk about that they definitely
talk about it after they're like oh I
regret this yeah but I don't feel like
they talk about it during and I I
definitely think it is harmful to your
mental state yeah we've had to do a lot
of like recalibration of like where
we're at okay because before
because when I first started I was like
making a ton of money and I was
traveling it was a complete new
lifestyle and everyone around me is in
the industry so it no longer becomes
weird I'm not in rooms having any of
these conversations because even the men
in the rooms are like in that industry
like it's just normal and becomes so
normal that
I just didn't care and when I pulled
myself away from that because I was
trying not to travel as much and I also
felt like hanging out with a lot of like
porn stars or only fans girls and I was
doing content their Instagram is bikini
photos and lingerie that's not what I'm
trying to do I don't want to be a bikini
model I want to do comedy and like have
the podcast so I started pulling back
from like collaborating with people and
taking time to myself to do other
content and then it was a complete shift
of how do I make content now I'm at home
now I'm like sitting with myself it's a
different vibe now and I don't have a
boyfriend anymore that like that's
happening with him M so it's like a fun
thing so there's a lot of like shifting
in there it can definitely weigh
mentally on you and I think it takes
you'd be mentally strong to be able to
even sit on a podcast like this where I
know like the audience will be like all
these ran through hoes you know what I
mean like not everyone can handle that
and I what you asked earlier like did
you think about
what people are gonna say beforehand and
that was absolutely like the main thing
it was like sit down yourself and you're
like are you okay with this are you okay
with people judging you are you okay
with people not taking you seriously or
respecting you and I had to which is
which is fine like my only like critique
sometimes of girls that like are in the
industries they'll complain later about
the consequences when they they kind of
knew them before you guys aren't doing
that so I'm not saying you are I think a
lot of people are selling a dream in the
industry and I see so many girls like I
want to try and only fans and I'm like
whoa whoa whoa what industry are you in
you have a normal job probably not the
best if you're not trying to go to
entertainment and do that long term or
be in some sort of entertainment space
20 grand online but a normal job also
might not take you after you do only
fans and that is something you have to
consider you have to consider that you
might have to be an entrepreneur for the
rest of your life and that gets
exhausting yeah so I have friends who
come to me and they're like oh like
should I start an only fans and I'm like
have you actually thought about it like
have you written like a pros and cons
list because you look at like our
Instagrams like look at the comments we
get would you be okay getting that all
not only that getting it and I've had
multiple of my friends have their sex
tapes or their nudes emailed and sent to
their parents and that is very common
because you get an angry subscriber
who's like [ __ ] you they screen record
and they send it to everyone you know
when they blackmail you and like you get
stalkers you get there's so many cons to
it that it really has to be worth it and
you're like can an average girl just
start and make good money the average
girl starts is not going to make the
money that I've made what would they
make can you explain just a little bit
about the economy of an omni fans page I
think a lot of average girl girls who
want to start and only fans are not
willing to promote it and if you're not
willing to promote it only fans does not
do any internal promotion there are some
websites that do but only fans is not at
all so if you're not willing to promote
yourself and really Market yourself
you're not going to make any money
you're biting yourself on the foot and
it's not worth doing because though
there are a ton of cons to it so like we
kind of had to make the decision like
are we going like ball so long like are
we going full into it and you have to
like make that commitment am I always
happy with the decision no but I'm I'm I
don't regret it for a second if you guys
didn't get married later would it still
be worth it if we never got married
because of only fans
I don't think it's going to be an issue
no I'm just asking hypothetically like
I'm not saying that'll happen I'm saying
it does happen no one will ever marry me
because of it no it's not it's something
it's not that no one would ever ever
let's just say hypothetically no I'm
saying it's it's that a lot of times the
guys you want won't marry you okay
there's always there will always always
yeah yeah there will never be yeah it's
just you want to marry me yeah it's just
like I mean look at um I mean what's her
name Mia Khalifa yep I mean she got
married and then she divorced him
wanted
I think
my biggest purpose based on my trauma is
to help people I think like a lot of
there's a lot of mental health stuff
that isn't talked about enough in these
conversations and everything and I have
a story to tell based on like my
childhood and the growth that I've done
that could help people in those
situations I'm okay with kind of taking
the hit
if that means I get to like make an
impact on people in another way
so would it suck like I eventually would
like to get married but I also don't
even know if I'd want to raise my kids
here if I did get married
so you would say it would be worth it
yes
yes yeah okay right
right um I think it would definitely
like in this type of cool hypothetical
situation I think it would hurt me
because I like especially coming from
like my background with my trauma I want
to be loved everybody wants to be loved
and I think if I wasn't married it would
require a lot of like inner work and
inner healing in order for me to feel
okay with not having that love in that
way and I would need to look for it in
other ways whether I have a golden girl
situation where I'm hanging out with my
best friends and we're like we have a
community of only fans girls yeah that
never get married you know but I I think
some part of me would be upset but I
don't think I would regret it because
that's just the path my life had to take
really that's so interesting I don't
think that's going to be the answer why
do y'all want to get married why do we
want to get married I think there's
nothing more powerful than like a bond
between like two people like two people
who are really into each other love each
other support each other like the stuff
that you can create together as long as
you make 150.
all right
but uh I'll take 150. oh [ __ ] yeah as
long as you make 150 and the bond is
going to be right
yeah I think you can you can create a
lot I think families are awesome and
having kids and all of that so so if I
make 150 okay
back to the regular dude
I make a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars a year
right
take him back he makes 70 though he's a
really good guy okay he looked at your
content said you know what I can get
past it I can rock with that but I want
you
and that's no good though right 70 is no
good
um no I've dated men who've made 70k but
she's but the minimum is 150 though well
right now I think because I've made more
money it definitely went higher so so if
I'm making something do make a 70. if I
have an undeniable connection with
someone they're my ride or die they
support me they build me up then at the
end of the day we're gonna figure it out
financially and I have no problem
supporting my man and and taking on a
role that helps us build together like
what I care about at the end of the day
is having somebody that like I know is
for me and I'm for them and I think that
is way more important than what I meant
70 for the rest of your life
and then adjusting for inflation is no
good though right what I want somebody
who's okay with just staying at that
level no I would not but
wait I'm sorry could you what percent of
guys do you think make that amount of
money
150. 150 oh that's like top one percent
right yeah I thought type one percent
was 500 no
no
damn one percent's only 150. that might
be a percentage of a percent I think I
think like less about how much money you
make and like what are your goals and
aspirations are you growing are you
working on yourself if you stay stagnant
and you're just making that money like
I'm just gonna look at you as at 70 000
person
at 70 you know the average household
income isn't even seventy thousand in
the United States of America
yeah and that's the household and isn't
it like a hundred dollars
families have more divorces because
based off of like a couple hundred
dollars if they had more Financial
Security and a couple of hundred dollars
more they actually wouldn't be having as
many issues as they are I don't think so
I think Financial stress plays a huge
role in marriages and divorces what do
you think
and it could be over a couple but a
couple hundred dollars is not going to
be the determining factor for whether or
not but if it's a couple hundred dollars
every couple years or every month think
about what y'all just said
no I mean they're actually right a
couple hundred dollars a year that
stress adds up I mean what I don't you
know I'm not a stats person right but
what is it like 60 of families in the
United States can't get like
four hundred dollars in cash in 30 days
in 30 days so I mean a flat tire can can
represent debilitate you catastrophe for
so many families and so and I think it's
even more maybe it's like 40 percent
can't get uh
four hundred dollars and then like sixty
percent of families can't get like a
thousand or something like that but
something super low and in 30 days so
when she sang you know 200 300 can can
make a break a family or at least put
extreme pressure on a relationship and a
marriage absolutely right I mean these
families are struggling in America yeah
but 70k
70 is like the new like 30. with
inflation it's getting bad no it's
getting really bad at immediately where
we got like the average household income
is under average across the entire
United States of America
under 70.
I don't think about it like this that's
the average household that's everybody
in the house right working together and
I asked you if you would be satisfied
with just one person him specifically
making 70. that don't mean that you
can't go get a job too oh if I can get a
job then absolutely there we go
the first place because I feel like a
lot of it just like I guess in the
situation that you're in like your wife
works underneath you and with you like I
think a lot of people want that they
would rather their like wife working for
them than like out at another job but I
mean she still works though is my point
yeah but you're amazing I've created a
space where where she's able to add
value into what it is that I've already
built
but that don't absolve her from working
even so I've dated somebody I did while
I was in sales and I was making uh six
figures
um my significant other at the time was
making like 80k and I had another I
guess two boyfriends one was making 50K
um and he came from a rich family like
Daddy's Money drove like Jaguars and had
Ferraris and all this stuff and so he
was so used to being like the rich one
and then he dated me and he was all
about me like being a a boss [ __ ] and
all that stuff and he supported me and I
think because he was in sales he had a
long sales cycle so his him's closing a
deal is once every six months I was in
marketing I'm closing deals the moment I
pick up the phone so I get home I'm like
I just closed three Deals and hit my
quota and it's like very exciting and
I'm making money and I think it put he
didn't like that I made more money than
him like was an insecurity thing so it
really depends on like the situation
what's my job how much money am I making
if he's making 70 and I'm making a
hundred
that the ego battle not on my end but
just like making him feel insecure
because I'm more of the provider there'd
be an issue I'm just
six figures so I'm just like wondering
where like where this comes from because
I I hear it's really common like like I
hear girls say it all the time but it's
like that's a top one percent guy like
what what makes I would even say me like
I wouldn't think like what makes me so
special that I deserve a one percent guy
so I guess well you grew up very
privileged so you your parents make good
money like you so if anything you would
think I'd be the one saying it you would
think
but if you've never experienced what
it's like to not eat like not have heat
or like cold like or warm water to like
struggle because and you watch your
family like destroy themselves over
trying to provide for you as like a kid
like you spend your whole life wanting
to do everything to avoid that and I
think a lot of women go right into like
okay men will be the provider and
they're going immediately up to that
do I necessarily think that's like
every person should have that
expectation absolutely not but I think
Financial insecurity drives a lot of
decisions of what people make yeah I
don't know really really good friend
she's homeless for a while she would
never say six figures I don't know why
it just comes like I just don't know
where it comes from
I guess it's because I know I can make
it and I know like I'm a hustler and I
want someone that has those those
qualities so then I can step more into
like my femininity and not be a freaking
Hustler but I feel like I can still be
feminine even if I make money yeah yeah
for sure it's something like women
really have a
bolster by the fact that women can look
around and see let's say unattractive or
fat or otherwise undesirable women with
men that make six figures right so if I
can look around and see five women who
look worse than me with men with six
figures like well of course I can get
one if you give me enough time right if
I can get a man making 150 000 why would
I settle for a man making 70. and it's
proof that I can get this man with 150
000 because I'm seeing all these other
women with men who make 150 000 and
these women look worse than me
but the other side of that though is
that a lot of those women were with
those guys way before he started making
150 000 dollars
I absolutely do believe in like sticking
with your man as he grows so like if a
man's like hey I'm making food Decay now
but here are my goals and this is what I
want to do then like yeah let's eat [ __ ]
together well like because you're
working on that you just said that your
traumas wants you to they make you one
but at that point I'm more I'm
financially secure but you're not though
because the guy's making 50 Grand so but
what if I'm making 100K and I can
provide a sense a little bit of a
contradiction there because at first you
said that your trauma's made it to where
you wanted to be as far apart uh from
the situation where you know you have to
eat [ __ ] and you don't have housing and
Light and Water and now you're saying
well you know if my guy is poor you know
I'm fine with that as long as at some
point we're working into the future I
can understand how that's contradicting
absolutely but I think when we talk
about our trauma like
just because I have those feelings and
just because there's that Financial
insecurity I think before I never worked
through that and that led to how I moved
in terms of dating well that's an
important thing I think working through
that trauma allows me to be a little bit
safe and not be like so oh my God we
need money and it's gonna be like the
end of the world if they're not making
good money does that make sense
no but also in this scenario we've
extended it to where he's not the only
provider where you guys said we could
also be working so if a man's making 70k
and I can't work and make up that
difference then maybe I couldn't date
somebody only making 70k if I can work
and I'm making enough money where I feel
stable and I don't have to worry about
that two three hundred dollar windfall
then he can make less until he works
towards making more as I would be doing
if we're both career people would you go
down and lifestyle for a family you yeah
yeah absolutely no traveling yeah at all
yeah I don't believe that no um what
about no new clothes like you can get
clothes once a year it's like 300 bucks
that's honestly pretty much what I spend
now oh yeah I don't need to drink so
like I don't I don't have anything
designer I don't I don't like to like I
don't invest in like nice stuff pretty
much because I don't like take care of
it but so like I don't spend a lot on
clothes like what I'm spending money on
is like the podcast the guy I dated a
man who had a two-year-old son and he
was separated from or you're not
together with the baby mama and I was in
sales and I was making more money than
him and he everything kind of clicked
for me like I need a man who has like a
good family because I don't so I think
that's very important so he had the good
family they liked me I had a good
relationship with his son and it was in
New Hampshire do I want to live in New
Hampshire and did I want to do that no
but I loved him and I loved his son and
I loved his family and I was willing to
put that first
um and I think when that hair dye what
no hair dye I didn't I didn't even have
red hair then I did this for the
lifestyle we're going down in no hair
dye yeah go back to Brown what about
this is more for marketing because
you'll always remember the two redheads
even if you don't know her name
actually
yeah
if I had a family then my family would
100 be my first priority and if I was
married to somebody and they loved me
they would not give a [ __ ] about I was
not wearing makeup yeah but I'm saying
so like then what about the so then why
do we need the 120 150 I just don't want
to go and we can go down and lifestyle
like Auntie Jenny was telling me she
thinks she could really just a kid with
like two to five hundred a month that's
actually no I've been talking to wives
that actually do this and it's literally
like they never eat out they never they
cook every single meal yeah only buy the
food that's like clear it like and I
haven't lived this so I'm maybe maybe
they're capping I don't know but I've
talked to like multiple wives that are
telling me no you can you can live on
this amount of money but like people
don't want to go down in lifestyle they
don't want to live outside of the city
and commute basically for their husbands
yeah um it's gonna be open to it for the
right person okay so you would so then
maybe maybe 45 000 a year yeah you'd
give a chance of your family I think but
here's the thing it's just like how you
said like well why would someone pick
you when there's other options in terms
of like only fans it's the same thing
with like lifestyle like I might not I
might go down in lifestyle from me being
able to travel twice a month to Mexico
and la and do all of that
but I'm not and I'm not spending as much
money we're not going out maybe we do
like once a month a family dinner that
goes out like or something like that I
could easily do that but do I want to go
back to like a struggling situation or
where it's like we're pinching pennies I
don't think so that's supposed to just
don't go down in Lifestyles willingly
they don't and you know
you know you might have an employee
that's not performing but the last thing
you can do is give them a demotion you
can't I'm going to cut your face you
don't follow them
yeah so you know we're kind of being a
little Cavalier saying yeah I'll just go
down in life well these are hypothetical
this is also would I be doing this we
want to tell the truth just because
they're hypothetical doesn't mean so
this in this hypothetical scenario I'm
picturing like something happened to a
job or like there's unemployment and we
have to make these cuts
um I don't think I would necessarily go
into a relationship knowing I would have
to raise a family on 45 how about this
is just the average guy but he would
make a good husband and a family you
know maybe getting close to geriatric
practices I don't know and you're just
we're thinking you know what
it's time to settle down
the rich men aren't biting this he's a
good guy
he's he's a good guy you know what I'm
gonna just go down in lifestyle so we
can have a family
uh no
I wouldn't want to raise my kids to have
a similar upbringing as me or we had to
be stressed where I had to as a child
worry about foreclosure and making sure
that I was working so that my family
wouldn't have to cover like School
expenses or or field trips like I don't
want my kids to have to experience that
I think so I wouldn't have a family what
if it was
because the lady I'm thinking of she
just lives in less than ten thousand
dollars a month like her husband like
let's say you have enough money for
savings and like you can put 20 of your
income away but you have to stay below
she lived last month less she had less
than less than ten thousand a month oh
yeah sorry for the kids a year
between the two parties or just her
um like raising the kids households
because I wouldn't have kids yeah I
don't think I would have kids
this is crazy her husband makes six
figures she's gonna do an episode of
wife school to show how she like how she
lives so cheap
so she said so you saying that her
disposable income they just save it yeah
but I'm telling you like she sent me
videos of how they live they just live I
couldn't live like that they also don't
want to raise my kids spoiled I think
that there's definitely something I
learned coming from a family that didn't
have money like a different kind of work
ethic I tried really hard in high school
as a result I don't think I would have
tried as hard if my family wasn't like
struggling but I think with like having
my biggest thing if I'm going to have
kids is giving them the best lifestyle
that they can have and the like the
least amount of like worry and I think
often when families are going through
financial difficulty or like whatever it
is even if they're keeping it from their
kids like the kids pick up on that kids
are smart and they feel that they can
feel the pressure maybe like the parents
are now a little bit more stressed that
that affects the children and like their
growth and I don't want to put that on
my kids but let me let me ask you all
the question though okay so you want the
life I mean let's be clear like you want
the life you want to fly here and there
you want to have nice cars you want to
be able to go shop over in the Design
District I mean right it sounds good
though in an Ideal World
not yet but that's what you want though
right yeah yeah but I don't need it cool
I'm with that right
so you meet this guy and he has the
ability to be able to give you that
what separates you from any other girl
that would validate him actually giving
you that lifestyle why would he give you
that
versus giving somebody else that or I
make a sandwich
it's a lot of girls that make sandwiches
and give phenomenal heads
I mean the sandwiches
but I mean for real like what what would
why would he choose you my Kick-Ass
personality and your personality and
loyalty on my titties
[Laughter]
the answer should be to that
um what should what should women bring
to the table
I'm gonna just be honest honestly I mean
I was with the sandwich in the blood
for me
um I think that if a guy reaches a
certain status in life
and he's not young right let's just say
he's above the age of 33 34 years old
right
um I don't see why he would choose
any woman to marry
once he reaches a certain threshold
interesting I don't see why he would
choose any of them you think he should
want the connection I think men want he
can have a commit connection with as
many women as he wants but that a deep
connection and intimacy and like real
like so stress you can't get that with
anyone you're not going to get that why
can't you she's gonna suck your dick and
then leave and then be not you know what
I mean you're not having that
communication you're not building
something men want I don't really think
you understand men no I think she's the
right thing no the majority of men
listen I've taught the majority of men
my whole Adult Career I coach him every
day lead I I disagree you know do you
coach like the the guys who are really
trying to get it or do you coach the
average man how much I think that how
much of your coaching sessions
they're a lot they're a lot are they
over a thousand I don't wanna I don't
want to say it online okay if there's a
lot then that by definition means that
you're not coaching the average man
because the average man can't afford it
so don't tell me you coach the average
man because it's not true but I Mentor
yada a lot of guys and I knew that the
coaching the coaching is different than
the mentor right don't in fact coach
that no no no but see here's here's the
caveat though lead because the coaching
session I don't know I'm gonna add the
content that you coach I'm gonna add the
contacts if you don't no no no I have a
certain amount of slots
that I a lot for regular people
yeah pretty much right but and those are
the regular guys so the coaching
sessions is completely different from
the guys that you allocate a specific
amount of your time to be able to hear
from regular people because I don't want
to become so disconnected it's true but
the charity cases are a small percentage
because you don't have a lot of time
that's true but I do I do talk to a lot
of guys though
talk to some regular dudes right I get
it I get it but what I'm saying is what
she's saying is is is is the fact most
guys really want a connection with a
woman it's true but that's not what we
talking about she's specifically no she
the question was when you reach a
certain threshold the type of guys that
they want they want the top one percent
you speaking about regular guys
they're saying I want guys that make 150
000 or more
a guy that's 20 years old on average is
not making 150 000 a year
when you start to get to a certain
threshold because most guys is making
that type of money are well into their
careers or they're they're starting to
get into that that ascending into 33 34
maybe 40 years old when those type of
guys make that type of money if they're
not already married why would they
choose them
I think the question is like why would
we care about being chosen by those
people who don't want a connection if
you're already having the mindset of
like men don't want that if I'm talking
to a man he's like hey I don't want
connection this is X Y and Z and I want
a wife in this way and he's not in a
position to give me what I want
emotionally that I can also pour into
him and help build him as a man that
he's not even a consideration I don't
care because first you can't build a man
that's a you can't build a man that's
already established as making that type
of money he's already him I think
there's a lot of men who are in
relationships
as a result of being married hear me out
no you can't build a man that's already
established he's already dedicated
growth no growth as a person
listen when you get to 70 you you don't
want the regular guy
y'all don't want regular dudes that's
what y'all said yeah that's what I'm
going off of they don't want under
121.50 for whatever reason whether it
was childhood trauma or whatever like
that they don't want that guy right so
they're not trying to build with a dude
that makes 50 60 70 000 a year on
average so when you take that into
consideration now you have to change the
terms you got to change the dynamic of
what that relationship is going to look
like because you're not talking about
building with a dude you're talking
about you talking about getting with a
dude that's already established so why
would that dude choose them that's that
God is pick of the litter
he could he his time is is is slammed
most of those types of billions
that's what that means but like what if
you're what if I could what if we could
be his peace what if we can like you
know what I mean there's there's a lot
of
there's a lot of factors that play into
it both of us did say we would build
with a man if he was willing to build
not willing to stay stagnant I don't
want an average man that's stagnant I I
don't mind being with a man making less
money if he's building and I absolutely
think that there's you know healing and
life experience that I have that I could
teach him in like are we saying that you
don't mind building with a man who's
making 150 or you don't mind building
with a man who's making 50. I don't mind
building with a man who's making under
150 if he's willing to work and make
sure I know that's a big gap 50 and 1
. I dated the guy who was making 50.
building with the guy that makes 50. I
dated a man that had zero that was
making nothing a year so yes I would be
okay dating a guy making 50. okay so
then where did this whole 120 and 150 I
think we asked for a hypothetical of
like what what
minimum I asked the minimum what was the
floor so now we're going yeah if I get
to choose but also like if I have a good
connection with someone I meet somebody
and we're vibing we have a good
connection they have good morals and
values and we're aligned on that then
that's gonna do it at Target with the
red shirt do they make 50k yeah
he's a manager at Target right he's all
he's overseeing uh the Home Goods
section you rocking the 30 off yeah
let's go baby you rolling with him we
about to home decor the [ __ ] out of this
yeah right you're rolling with him right
I'm rolling with him I don't think I
know I wouldn't date a man who works at
Target because I that's like where
you're at if you're a salesperson you're
making 50k in two years you could build
a clientele business you could be making
more like again there's goals absolutely
I would date you at 50k yeah but I just
think like I think he's asking like
what's the minimum for I mean we could
say it at different age it's okay I'm
26. I I like I was a little older than
me like most of us do yeah hell yeah
girl so yeah um so so let's say let's
say 30 right let's say 30 and up that's
a little young okay
so like there's a minimum that he has to
be at by 30.
but for me to date him like he's making
25 000 a year unless he just started a
business or something you know I'm just
thinking like what have you been doing
the last 10 years yeah no I agree with
that and that's honest right so if if
he's not making 125 000 a year I'd be I
I'm fine like he can make 50 60 or you
know but I'm saying like what is the
minimum and he's 30. so he's like he's
getting up there in age I'm never gonna
happen I still think it's so nuanced I
don't think it's on I'm never gonna have
a woman coaching me on my money that's
not what I said I would how you could
help build a man though we're not
coaching him about his money though what
if I see a man who has like really good
qualities but there's I don't know
um he gets angry a little bit does not
control his emotions if I have emotional
intelligence I can be like oh here's how
you do this so that you could you know
not let your emotions get the best of
you in situations like I think there's
ways that you can support a man when a
man maybe doesn't feel good I think
there's a lot of things now with men
where they feel insecure about their
place in the world with women who are
like I want the only one percent male
you know what I mean and I think I think
you can build Demand by showing him that
he's worthy that you think he's valuable
I don't see because I'm just thinking
I'm thinking you don't need it no I'm
just I'm thinking of the men I know that
like make six figures you know or like
The Meta note they are going to be
successful with or without them I've
never dated a man that says they haven't
learned girl the girl might have like
helped thank you I've never dated a man
that says he hasn't learned something
from me that I didn't provide value in
that way I'm not saying you can't learn
anything I'm not saying you can't learn
anything from you I'm not saying you
can't you can't have provided value in
the relationship I'm saying like a lot
of times I think women take credit for
the men's success more than they really
deserve it's like yeah you worked at his
business or yeah you helped him out but
like he was going to be successful with
or without you I think that's completely
disregarding the the home like the
Homemaker role so if this is a man that
gets to completely devote his life to
making money and she's focused on
building the family and making sure he
has meals three times a day or what have
you and she's really building that home
I think saying that she didn't
contribute to his success is well then
how are you gonna have a housekeeper a
nanny a babysitter all of that wrapped
up in one and you just get to work
denying the fact that homemaking is a
complete job absolutely love and adore
my wife she understands I was going to
be my I was going to be me regardless of
whether or not but then maybe you
wouldn't have had a family until you're
50. I was okay with not having a family
if that wasn't a criteria that the
determining factor for whether or not
she was going to come in or not okay I
was okay with not having a family my
goal was to get rich my goal was to be
successful I was going to be that with
or without her now it doesn't mean that
she doesn't add value or it doesn't mean
that I don't appreciate the fact that
she's a great mother or whatever so on
and so forth but she didn't make me cool
of course yeah absolutely and she can't
take credit for My Success either no
you're right no you did that correct but
which is how she helped provide
what she benefits
like what did what did she do two things
can be true what did she do that a nanny
if she's a nanny no what did she do than
a nanny chef
and a maid couldn't so that's a that's a
good question is a sex worker
huh is a housewife a sex worker
no but she's you're providing for her
and then she's [ __ ] you and she's
[ __ ] you because she's providing no
she's funny because she can have
problems too
well you know what well your way
no I think both parties you're not doing
me a favor yeah what's your favorite
yeah but there are definitely some
relationships where that is the case
no my whole point is like I just think a
lot of girls take credit for a guy's
success and well I think a lot of guys
will say their wife supported them and
helped them like I just think they're
going to be successful regardless again
build a man do you think that women it's
a lot of it's a lot of use it's only one
of me
let's be clear
because a lot of chicks don't realize
that the guy is the prize
the guy is the prize listen marriage is
more beneficial to women than it is to
men but if guys are the prize women like
men have wars over women no men lose
Wars over women
the downfall of every great Kingdom came
as a result of a man simping over a
woman
and placing more value over a woman than
he should and that's on the man which
means that he should have been more on
his purpose instead of focusing on a
woman that sounds like a him problem it
is
but now the difference is that guys are
starting to wake up and saying I'ma
focus on the me problem instead of
focusing on her and then it leaves a lot
of y'all out in the cold because y'all
don't really understand the value or you
overvalue what you bring into the
household because we don't in reality we
got doordash we got uh Zumba the room
thing that's do the floor we got
dishwashers
we don't even women are nurturers they
create they create life like to say that
to act like there's no value in that
completely diminishes what it means like
to be a woman and have like that role as
a woman yeah I'm not saying it's like
we're just like objects that you have to
like cater to you because you're
successful I'm not saying that like
women I'm not saying women bring no
value to these guys but I will say when
you actually talk to the Homemakers and
the women like you've I swear to God
I've never been humbled so quick I am
not no I've never been humbled so quick
when these women were telling me what
they doing today it's like these women
make all their meals from scratch that
they got like this girl Gardens herself
yeah she Gardens herself she makes all
her meals from scratch she she cooks she
clean like oh my God I'm gonna have her
on the channel we're gonna do a wife's
full episode that's a woman but I'm just
saying like most women don't bring what
a lot of these women bring to the table
I I absolutely agree that there is
there's some delusion in what
people provide in their value I don't
think it's all a delusion I don't think
it's that black and white and I think
that there's a lot of people you want to
talk about living in fairy tales like
men are living fairy tales they want
their dick sucked they want food they
want to they want a maid they want a
hooker they want someone who it like
doesn't take any value or like any
ownership of like what they brought to
the table being away you just let me
take big boobs and head no I was
repeating
everything that you just said you can do
within an hour
cook clean have sex in an hour you can
do all of that [ __ ] within an hour it's
like have you done it I mean have you
been married since you were 22 have you
ever taken on that role of sitting back
and you be that the person who's taking
care of the kids and taking care of the
house because I absolutely bet you
wouldn't be able to do it the way that a
woman would do it take all of that heat
take all of that stress and then still
look at you as a man and make you feel
like a man and valued and then still
want to [ __ ] you the kid is at school
the majority of the day what are you
doing that's so valuable throughout the
day that that brings so much wealth into
the house doesn't your wife also work no
no no no no no no no you can't answer a
question with a question what do you do
a kid go to once the kid becomes a
kindergartner and a first grader they're
going to school full time they in school
the majority of the day what are you
doing throughout the day that's so
valuable to me meanwhile I'm working 16
hours a day seven days a week what are
you doing but if I'm working what are
you doing what are you doing I'm working
no no you're a housewife what are you
doing I'm a housewife yeah
hmm depends how big the house is the
shopping the organizing the kids
schedules the getting them there the
cleaning the laundry the food for you
the like just making sure that the home
is in good order making sure their
mental health that they're also you're
the only one there able to provide
energy I got one kid and you're the only
one there what are you talking about
what about the husband you got a
dishwasher it ain't like you scrubbing
the doing the thing where they you ain't
gotta uh washing machine and dryer
anymore everything is automatic
you can even order your groceries and
they'll deliver it right to your door we
got it it's all of us now that is very
nice and roombas can wash and vacuum
to say again my thing is awesome
there's a lot of mental labor that goes
into building a house the problem with
women completely the problem with women
is that they're too arrogant in thinking
that they bring more value than they do
instead of too arrogant to think that
women bring no value the problem with
men is that they're not they're not
really truly understanding how valuable
they are and they put more stock into
what a woman is which is one of the
reasons why they get distracted and they
don't get rich and they only wind up
making 50 and 60 000 a year because they
so Focus dedicating a time to a woman
instead of focusing their time on a
vision the woman is a help me you can't
take credit for the greatness of a man
ever
you will never take credit for the any
time that a woman is is arrogant enough
to not to to believe that she can take
credit for what it is that that guy is
building don't deserve to be in a
relationship or get married to that guy
and a man that's not willing to give
credit to a woman that built him up and
took care of roles that he did not want
to take care of is not
him up yes
Yes actually however you build up here
Build Me Up sexually oh honey you've
never had a good then
is this a fair analogy let's say pearl
extremely uh successful YouTube channel
let's just say that she had one editor
all right and it's an editor but it's a
really good editor and some of the clips
that the editor has made has has blown
the channel up right is it fair for
Pearl to say listen I know you're a good
editor but I was going to be me
regardless where the editor says hey you
know I'm a part of your success right is
this kind of an analogy yeah
knew I would have just found a new
editor because I think like think about
if you're going through like a stressful
time at work like you go home and that
woman can hopefully like distract you
from that take ease that off of you like
there's a benefit from that emotional
connection that you get that you can
take the next day into your work to
become the man but is she responsible
and like you wouldn't have done that
without you no but I I do believe that
like she can help by being that I just
think like we overvalue what that's
worth like it's replaceable just like
the good editor it would be hard for me
and that's why I think people need to
focus on the things that aren't
replaceable that's character that's
integrity that's loyalty that's like
being able to communicate with us being
able to let a man leave there's a lot of
girls out there
it is there's a lot of like and I'm I'm
not saying like it would be very hard to
replace my editor he's great
he's literally I cannot feel that but
it's like but it's like you can find
another and that's just that's how guys
that have money look at it because again
all of the highest quality women are
chasing after those guys it's not like
they have they have a shortage of women
all right Rebecca I'll talk to you and
again that's why we agreed that there is
definitely some like delusion or like
people not being able to see people
exaggerate their worth and they're not
working on themselves to actually be
there you'd be delusional because you
guys said the 127 150 000 like that oh I
live my life delusional that's how I got
here that's how I've been able to grow
and get out of poverty if I didn't think
delusionally and I listened to what
everyone said I would be I probably
would not be here right now okay
delusional I think be delusional be a
little crazy and then how old would you
have to be before you'd be like you know
what
is there an age where you'd like lower
the standards no okay never no so so
okay
I think
I'm just thinking like okay geriatric
pregnancies at 35. yeah yeah 37 38 it's
not looking good you probably it's
probably over with rough yeah roughly
over with so like at what age are you
like you know what
she said never no you know but at that
point I wouldn't lower my standard I
just simply would find something else to
occupy my time maybe I would be
childless maybe I buy a dog
there's so many options other than
lowering my skin she got a couple ideas
this is insane well I I think it's so
normal though because again we have to
remember age right every single 24 year
old thinks like this every single one I
will never ever ever I think I have been
not my wife I'm like now 29 and I can
tell you well that's what I'm saying I
was the problem and relationship you
said you're 29. I'm turning I'm 28 I'm
turning 29. but a little different girl
but generally speaking every woman when
she's 20 22 to 23 she's in the prime of
her career a prime of her let's say
sexual market value in her and she's
like why would I lower anything look at
all that I've got because she's not me
she's not able to see she's not there
yet now he's going to be at 33 and 35.
she also doesn't have these biological
clocks taken at 22 and 24 like she's
gonna have at 35 and 37 right yeah and
so to ask her to see and and to to guess
how she's gonna feel 15 years into the
future like there's there's no way she
can seek it I also know I've lowered my
standards in the past when I was younger
and people might say I was more in my
Prime back then you lowered your
standards though for the reasons that
you might lower your standards in the
future you have no idea what that looked
like it looks you're right I don't I
think when I was 22 and 24 I definitely
had like
um not like delusional but like
hopefully I'll look or
mis-informed Outlook because I didn't
have the experience and going through
like a couple of relationships and I was
dating I thought that those each time I
was in that relationship that I was
working towards something
I blamed especially the breakups like I
was cheated on in multiple relationships
and I blamed them like you're an [ __ ]
you're the worst like all of this stuff
I never looked inward of like how I was
like affecting that and just thought I
deserve the best and deserved all of
that
now as I'm getting like older I I had to
take an inward look at myself and be
like okay maybe your shit's not ice
cream maybe you need to work on yourself
to be that person you know what I mean
and then you take a step back and then
you can kind of like readjust I don't
think I think a lot of women do spend
majority of their lives in that like
mindset from when they're 22 and it
never leaves and they don't do any of
the work internally to or like to be
that person that deserves all of that
stuff but you committed you know you
committed to the delusion I also don't
think I'm at the level where I would
date the person that I want to date like
I don't think I'm there yet and a lot of
women think they're there and they're
they don't have to do anything to be
there I think you do have to put in work
and like Jamie said heal yourself and do
the inner work and maybe you have to go
to wife school or learn etiquette
there's things you can do to improve
yourself so you can get to that level
where it's not delusion and it's like oh
I'm on this level this is what I'm
bringing into the table and now I can
meet somebody at the same level I don't
think I'm at that level where I can get
that guy in that one are you saying like
emotionally like where where you're at
emotional definitely emotionally I think
I'm still very immature this is what I
mean when I just I feel like it's women
like we just say things
[Laughter]
but do you not like think that if we
want somebody on that level we would
have to work to get there at 24 years
old you will never be more valuable than
you are right now
she
that's right yeah I guess to the average
man
oh
be delusional baby I don't know look it
why'd you laugh Lee
I mean I don't know I it can't be that a
hundred percent of a woman's value is
wrapped up in her looks at 24. it's not
early we're ability to have a child it's
the idea that
it's the idea that
the older she gets
the more bodies she gonna rack up
the more men that she's going to go
through
the more trauma she's going to
experience
and then at some point
based off of what they're saying they
they're gonna still live in the delusion
so no I I agree with you any sock in
what she says the 24 year old talking
about she's never going to settle
that's like talk to me in five years
yeah we'll see in five years is
oh you know do you like girls do you
want to kiss girls like no oh that's
disgusting this is what this is what it
is ask me a 24 year old she's gonna
settle right because she's she's not
she's not gonna see it right so you
can't you can't count the problem with
that is that she's old enough to start
her only fans
and then she's old enough to [ __ ]
and she's old enough to go out here and
make some decisions that's that she'll
never be able to undo you'll never be
able to not have that content out there
floating in in space somewhere you'll
never be able to take some of this stuff
back
so the value that you have is in your
decisions to not make bad decisions
that's why age is a factor not just in
what it is that you look like but it's
in the decisions that you make that's
gonna that she's gonna have to carry for
the rest of her life I agree with you I
actually I agree with you on it but the
perspective that we're looking at from
and like that lens is there are women
who at 35 they spent their life having
these like thoughts and these standards
and they get there and they don't do the
work so when you say they have more the
reason they're more valuable when
they're younger at 24 is because they
don't have as much baggage from being
with multiple women and everything those
are people who are not healing their
baggage like absolutely if you're a 35
and you can't get married because you
never did any of the work to heal that
and you're not taking like a fresh start
with like you should really hear what
men think when you say healing oh girl
oh my God I can't believe you just said
that
oh they think that then you can say
otherwise so after you're gonna be like
that's not what I meant I'm telling you
no matter what you say next this is what
they hear oh absolutely I've been ran
through I know I mean you guys already
have the only fans so that doesn't help
um but like
I'm just being honest like telling you
guys see it you know look it I've been
ran through I've been at the club I've
been healing under Tyrone yeah this is
this is so there's a lot of there's a
lot of weaponized women who like who
like weaponize uh therapy terms and and
like healing healing is actually doing
like looking inward to like the darkest
parts of yourself where you don't even
realize their issues and taking
accountability for where you've [ __ ]
up and where you've had like where
you've made mistakes like what what made
me hook up with guys who didn't deserve
it I had to look Inward and do that
healing and really heal whatever that
core thing was for my family trauma to
no longer move that way so to come like
I understand men don't want to hear
healing but to completely disregard that
I think is stupid because there are
people who actually do that work and men
can do that too in certain ways there's
plenty of men who were cheaters in the
past and now they're are committed with
their woman because they learned from
that they healed the need to just have
that instance
where they got better at cheating that
is absolutely true too some people get
real good with it but it's just like
it's just no matter what I mean you
could say not all but it's like then put
us in categories and that's how men
think they categorize them so if they
hear it okay Rebecca said she was
healing us our [ __ ] John last week
okay and then you know Danielle over
there said she was healing us here in
the club like five times this week you
know and it's like they just start to
see these and that's why action and what
you do actually as a result like you can
say [ __ ] all day long and I can talk the
talk and be like I'm a 10 and I do great
blah blah but if I'm not actually like
putting the work in to be that person I
saying I am then that's [ __ ] and I
can understand why there's people get
angry and they're like [ __ ] up and you
said she's healing you have to actually
see someone who's doing the work and
there's not a lot of people doing it
it's like the other side of this it's
like a lot of times when I hear like
healing and stuff like it just sounds
like nothing to me me yeah because it's
just like I like looked at my trauma but
it's like like it like I never hear any
like real work other than like looking
inside of yourself that's what I was
thinking when you said man hear healing
and they think like you've been run
through like no that's not I'm not
laughing but you do get to a point like
what you just said it's like you know
every woman is healing every woman is
manifesting every woman has to eat
praying loving right yeah and it's like
okay well what does that entail you
never you hear women talking about we're
doing the work there's never one detail
behind it it's never one details like
maybe I went to therapy and that's it
I'm healing I'm in the process it's it's
never concrete so if you listen to our
podcast two girls one blunt on Apple
podcast and Spotify also YouTube we talk
a lot about the details behind our
healing so me personally the healing
that I'm trying to do which is what
leads to baggage within relationships is
my parental trauma so what I'm I'm doing
is I'm going to therapy I'm doing
something called eye movement deep
processing something like that I don't
even know it's called EMDR and what it
does is it reprocesses your childhood
trauma and it allows you to
re-experience it and see it in a lens
where you don't feel like that scared
little person anymore yeah you don't
feel like the victim you feel safe you
feel secure so then when you come into
situations where you wouldn't normally
be triggered you would get that
emotional reaction be like oh he's
cheating on me because he did this when
in reality what you're actually saying
is my mother didn't love me and now I
feel abandoned and I think you're
cheating on me so when people are saying
they're healing are they actually doing
that childhood work that inner work
where they're really facing their demons
or are they just like oh I go to therapy
and I talk [ __ ] about John because I
don't like John anymore and I think he's
cheating like you really do have to look
at their actions and what they're
actually trying to do and get to know
the person the nurture like
re-traumatizing yourself yeah so you
said the only fans
it's like it's like you're healing but
then re-traumatizing that's very true I
gotta start I gotta start twice weekly
there oh my God you [ __ ] nailed it
right there he's like Jesus Christ
no that's a good point yeah no I don't
view I think healing is first of all
like it never ends
um but I think that growing confident
like doing only fans we start only fans
before we started those Journeys so are
you about to give it up before you meet
the guy of your dreams or before you
blow up
[Laughter]
but this is what I like and this is
surprising to me because you're so young
that you just seem so centered right and
so so so so so so you should have seen
me an hour ago when I was like I'm gonna
have to put my cat down because she just
threw up in the corner of my room
definitely am still anxious I think
you're super mature for your age and
being able to acknowledge a
contradiction and I think that's awesome
but Pearl like you called it out as true
and learning
I'm healing that's right
I really wanted to accommodate you both
because you're so young and uh both of
y'all seem you know seem very Sinners
and very mature for you thank you thank
you and that was the results of healing
if you if you saw me when I was 24 I was
emotionally unstable all the time
picking fights like I was super insecure
with boyfriends like I didn't know how
to have emotional intelligence where I
could separate my emotion from the
problem and having those conversations
why is this funny that's real [ __ ] I
mean even two years ago I was thinking
that my ex at the time was a problem but
I was a big part of the problem and a
big part of why we were so toxic I was
was feeding into it I was allowing
behaviors I was instigating just the guy
he was digmatized by yep oh yeah oh yeah
interesting but you're also with him for
a very long time right right in the
center
yeah focus is chakras it's all beautiful
should we all take a deep breath
I mean honestly I just think people just
need to be a lot more realistic where
where with what it is that they are and
where they slide in life and and not how
they feel about themselves
but in the views of the people that
they're seeking affection and love from
and so when you be more realistic I
think that you'll find that guys that
make 120 plus 150 000 dollars
they not they don't give a [ __ ] about
your healing
they don't care
they're not interested in being you know
and working with you through your drama
and
all your problems and all of that and I
and I think that you get one life
you're only gonna be 24 25 26 27 one
time
and you're not gonna have no undoes
right when you said men don't want to
deal with all that drama and all that
trauma and I think that there's not a
lot of accountability because that's not
on a man and that's that is on the sole
person of what they're going through and
a lot of women get into relationships or
start having sex because they're looking
for that man to to fix whatever's going
on and they put that responsibility on
someone else and when they when they're
like put them in their place and they're
like that's not how it is then there's
like a reaction like there's no
accountability in that so I fully agree
like and that's why I think as women
like they need to be doing all of that
work to deal with that so they're making
better choices and they can be better
people they're not putting that like
that [ __ ] essentially on a man I do
think that's also absolutely true that
men don't want to deal with it you know
what honest to God I don't want to deal
with my trauma either but I don't want
to deal with someone else's yeah I have
to and they don't wanna they don't want
to hear about it either
they don't like if you went on a date
and you're talking about this healing
it's like a red flag see I'm not used to
this right like I'm not used to this
like
I don't deal with this this is not what
happens in my household like I don't
have the healing and there that's so
it's very nice I don't notice I don't
know it's not that it's new okay I think
therapy like messes up half the girls
more I'm just gonna stay married you're
just thinking about your trauma all the
time like okay there it definitely can
[ __ ] with you and there definitely are
bad therapists I feel like I'm only
seen man better go to therapy that this
is just an unpopular opinion every every
time I have a girl and she goes to a
girl therapist she's always gone for
years
years it's like what it becomes like a
bond between them that's almost like a
motherly role they look to that person
again for that emotional validation I've
only been to therapy a couple times in
my life every time I was just like this
[ __ ] is stupid
well the only times I thought it was
somewhat reasonable was with guy
therapists interesting I'm not I'm not
saying they're a good Wayland therapists
but maybe I am looking for that motherly
Bond and that's why I do well with
female therapists as opposed to male
therapists
men look to fix problems where women
more like look to comfort you I agree
and I feel like yeah like male
therapists are looking to like solve the
problem and fix it or like women will
kind of comfort you and tell you what
you want to hear you might have changed
my stance on that I think I want to
change therapists yeah I absolutely
agree with that because I had a
therapist where I was like she was I was
just going in there and dumping like it
was like a vent session and she was like
you're right your mom does suck and like
you know like all that stuff and I'm
like okay so like what do we do about
that now like what are the steps that
I'm supposed to take and not a lot of
them are like providing any real insight
on like what to do with them yeah
they're just like you can cry to me
you'll see I'll take the check to like
next week
um
so I don't see that on the other hand I
also know somebody who went to a
therapist for 30 plus years and these
were two men talking to each other and
he was just continuing the problem he
was just feeding into it he was like oh
yeah you can vent to me talk to me about
your wife issues and then never actually
made a difference in this person that's
wild you guys are best friends yes 29 24
best friends how long I've known each
other three years yeah
well I hope this was a fun show thanks
for having us I appreciate it thanks for
coming guys we're gonna be uh By the
time this airs check out our our heated
debate on sauce Castle yes we're gonna
we're gonna go at it
thank you for co-hosting with me you
have anything you want to tell the
people just check me out on the lead
attorney uh YouTube channel
uh why don't you guys um tell them where
to find you any final thoughts
y'all go ahead I'm gonna let y'all go
first
um Jamie you can find me at the Jamie
Lee show and you can find our podcast at
two girls one blunt I do just want to
say thank you for having us on and I
think that you've been you know crushing
it and hustling and that's very
respectable and I appreciate you guys
for having a good conversation with us
and hearing us and a good debate so I
think it was a good conversation
thank you so much for having us on Pearl
you did a great job co-hosting I think
this is a great episode I feel like I
learned a lot you guys changed my mind
on certain things and that's what I want
in a conversation I don't want somebody
who's gonna blindly agree with me and
not force me to open my mind in some way
or another so I definitely appreciate
this conversation you can find me at
loud Emily on most platforms
it's called Loud Emily because I smoke a
lot of dank um you can find our podcast
at two girls one blunt like Jamie said
on all platforms again
and uh you can find us on onlyfans we're
best
friends.com Jamie Lee comedy I can give
you a free subscription if you want
you'll be doing therapy sessions back
there you're like what do you put on
your only fans actually I just talked to
men about their problems I let them cry
to me and they pay oh you can find me at
the lead attorney
on YouTube subscribe to the lead
attorney
[Music]
yeah and just put Anton Daniels a and
t-o in in the YouTube algorithm and
it'll pop right up so I love y'all I
love you Pearl I love you I love you
thank you guys
um also I'm doing an interview on your
channel yeah by the time this comes out
it'll be out so check it out there guys
guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell don't forget to
subscribe to both of our Clips channels
just for eclipse and pearl daily and
sign up for our memberships
um that way you'll get a one-on-one call
with me once a month in the fourth year
if you're trying to grow on YouTube I
really recommend that like the video on
your way out and I will talk to you next
time